we as Americans I think really struggle
with finding our own identity within
Shakespeare I think we generally have
this inferiority complex relative to the
the English there's still this adoration
for the idea of monarchy and the English
represent civility and intelligence and
divinity even when we you know American
actors try to take on Shakespeare it's a
real challenge to find our own voice
within it to find an American voice
within it to personalize it to resist
all the reverence and you know the
preciousness of it it really break it
down destroy it
recreated in our own image the person
who was most effective and that for me
was Chris Walken he played yaaah go to
the late Ron Julius a fellow and Chris
is a highly intelligent guy
but the way he was able to craft that
language was like nothing I'd ever seen
he didn't give in to anyone else's idea
about what this language was or who
Shakespeare was it was vicious and and
and improvisation and just brilliantly
his own and it's very rare thing that
American actors are able to do that they
hear people in this life is kind of you
know these faux British British into
nations or this Middle American ink
whatever that is but it doesn't speak to
you know a real persona so that's the
real challenge I think for us you know
as performers but also as as as readers
of Shakespeare really to you know to to
claim it for our own